- Good night and God bless.
- In the name of the father,
the son, and the holy spirit.
Shit.
- [Cameraman] And
cut, that was great.
- Felt good.
- Opp, I'm blowing
up. It's Michelle.
Hey sweetie. Yup.
Alright. Oh, Bo did what?
Rolled over and barked?
Well that's a fascinating talk.
Look I do have to run
because I am busy.
- I am very busy!
I mean damn, why
don't you just call me
the next time you take a dump!
Damn, girl. I'm tryna lead the
free world up in this bitch!
- No, that's Luther sweetie,
my anger translator. Yeah.
No I think he was
talking to his wife.
Okay. Yes, I will
definitely watch
the new Tyler Perry
movie when I get home.
- Are you out your mind!
After a busy day
dinner is all I need.
Please don't make me
watch a grown ass man
in a goddamn dress!
- I love you sweetie goodbye.
Luther. - Yes sir.
- Yeah I don't
need your services
during my personal stuff.
- Oh Luther, come on man
stay up out the man's life.
Stay up out the
man's personal stuff!
Shaklayka!